[Music]
here's worrying statistics for you
nearly one in five patients in the EU
claim to have experienced a serious
medical error in hospital and one in ten
say they've been prescribed the wrong
medication how much should we trust
medical authority medicine has never
been perfect and-and-and-and neither a
humans of course there's always going to
be human error but are these figures
much higher than they should be
to discuss these questions this
afternoon we've got a panel with a wide
range of expertise and a diverse set of
views I understand David Healy on my far
left is professor of psychiatry at
Bangor University and David has
published extensively on psychiatric
drugs in the pharmaceutical industry
including books such as the
antidepressant era and Farmageddon
pallavi Bradshaw is a doctor and acini
senior medio legal advisor at the
medical protection Society which
provides legal support and advice for
healthcare professionals
and Jacobs taganga is a philosopher of
science and medicine at the University
of Cambridge and Jacob is the author of
medical nihilism which takes a skeptical
view about the effectiveness of modern
medicine is medical authority to be
trusted or should we turn to intelligent
technologies so I'm going to ask each of
you in turn to talk about that for about
three or four minutes starting Jacob
with you okay thank you so I want to
start by noting that this question is a
false dichotomy so we could answer no to
both questions yes to both questions or
no to one and yes to another so should
we trust medical authority or should we
turn to intelligent technologies those
questions are independent and they
should be treated independently so we're
gonna talk about technologies sort of
towards the end of the debates so let's
start with Medical Authority should we
trust medical authority what do we mean
by medical authority do we mean the
clinician in the moment at which you go
to the clinic and you get diagnosed and
perhaps prescribed do we mean the
regulator's that are the real
authorities in Clinton clinical work do
we mean a thority in the literal sense
of the author's
of scientific articles so we're going to
get different answers to the questions
depending on depending on how we
understand Authority in a basic sense
some of you who are just at my talk you
might be surprised to hear me say this
and it basic sense I want to say yes we
should trust Medical Authority if you're
ill and you visit the doctor chances are
extremely high that they know more than
you do about what you're suffering from
and about what's gonna help you so of
course there are better doctors and
worse doctors but on the whole the
doctor is going to know better than you
and you should you should listen to them
so yeah you should trust Medical
Authority now there's a pernicious
movement in our society to doubt
expertise right so we see this in all
sorts of domains of life and you know
most prominently today we have figures
like Trump who denounce expertise in
this kind of post fact alternative fact
yura so so if you if one holds the view
that we should not trust Medical
Authority you run the risk of being
aligned with these dark forces of evil
these anti experts and we ought we ought
to avoid that so you know the title of
this debate is your life in the balance
and it's not just your physical life in
the balance when we're talking about
should we trust medical authority it's
your political life right so so if you
just start denouncing Authority
expertise then you run the risk of being
aligned with the trumps and none of us
want that okay so you should trust
medical authority sometimes if you are
in a cycling accident and you're
bleeding out on the side of the road you
better trust Medical Authority if you
were born with type 1 diabetes you
better trust Medical Authority when
you're you're a parent of a child
considering getting a vaccination for
your children you better trust Medical
Authority but on the other hand if you
have high cholesterol malignant cancer
mysterious pains depression there I'm
not so sure for those kinds of illnesses
physicians can't do much for you but
they're trained in really rigorous ways
with the mentality of intervening and we
as patients hope for the best for
ourselves and so we want an intervention
in those kinds of moments should you
trust your doctor should you trust
medical authority no so that leaves us
in a kind of perplexing dilemma I mean
on the one hand we should trust medical
authority for reasons that I just went
through we don't want to be aligned with
the dark forces of evil we don't want to
be Trump anti experts but on the other
hand we have really good reasons to
doubt medical authority and this is a
deep and difficult question thank you
well I'm a doctor you're all gonna say
of course you're going to defend doctors
and say we should trust a medical
authority but I think the important
point of this debate is has already been
raised it's not an either/or here we've
got medical experts and we have
technology and I think doctors are
embracing that and using it as an
adjunct but when I talk about medical
authority I am talking about the
clinicians that you go and see and I
would suggest that most of the time
these are highly trained experts doctors
who are there to help you they're not
there to you know purposely harm you and
they'll do the best for you and I think
what we need to also understand is when
we're going to a doctor is it simply
clinical expertise that we are looking
for and I think a lot of people will say
yes but there'll be a fair number of
people who will also think well actually
why am I going to see the doctor not
only do I want them to be a clinical
expert but I want them to be empathic
and compassionate and we know there are
studies that show that doctors who show
compassion their patients have better
outcomes
now that demonstrates to me that we
can't just see artificial intelligence
and new technologies as being the
panacea and we can't forget that and as
I say we're already embracing new
technologies I understand that you know
people will be skeptical in certain
areas for example as well with big
pharma but then what is the alternative
do we entrust artificial intelligence do
we trust people I
p.m. in Google do we leave them to be
basically in control of our healthcare
surely it's much better to have
individual doctors and nurses who
genuinely care about their patients and
have their best interests at heart
do we really trust those kinds of
companies to be doing the best for us as
patients and us as a nation and for the
NHS I have my doubts
also we would be sharing out in you know
confidential information with them or we
already know how some of those big
companies treat our confidential data so
again those are issues that we need to
think about and ultimately medical
authority and doctors in general do act
within the law they are ethical they are
highly regulated and they do what's best
for us as individuals and I would
suggest that there is no real
alternative I think suggesting that
there might be is foolhardy with we're
too far away at the moment from relying
on anything else it's the best we've got
it's lasted us for many millennia and I
genuinely think that we still should be
trusting in medical authority patients
obviously have more information now and
it's absolutely right that people take
control of their medical information and
about their health conditions and we
know about 50% of patients before they
go and see a doctor we'll have Google
their symptoms now sometimes that can
cause a challenge but some you know it's
good that people are being interested
and I certainly think that we need to be
taking more initiative with our own
health and asking the questions and
ultimately doctors won't impose their
views on you it's a two-way street we
need to have a dialogue and a discussion
and ultimately that's what autonomy is
about and patient autonomy and doctors
respect that so I think at this moment
in time it's the best thing that we've
got and we have to trust in medical
authority thank you David okay in the
last few years life expectancy in the
United States in the UK and France in
Germany has begun falling for the first
time since we began collecting data you
shouldn't trust doctors the authority
they may have had the mayor worked for
us up to 10 20 years ago isn't working
anymore and they're responsible they
need I mean they paid a lot of money
educated well they need to carry the can
they used to use the medical model which
I agree with and they used to use it to
make sure they didn't over treat people
but four of 50 percent of people over
forty five are on three or more drugs
that's polypharmacy fifty percent of
people over 65 are on five or more drugs
this is probably the reason life
expectancy is falling the human body's
not made to take three drugs chronically
a five drugs chronically it's made to
possibly survive or we could do of an
antibiotic it can maybe survive a few
months for an antidepressant but being
around these drugs for longer is not a
good idea being on multiple drugs for
longer is an even worse idea in terms of
the ethics and things that out of
doctors well you know a hundred percent
of the literature for any drug that any
of you are taking here in the room is
ghostwritten the people whose names only
or I mean sort of the word author was
hinted at as a component of the word or
authority well actually the author's
names on the authorship lines in the BMJ
and the New England Journal of Medicine
they aren't the authors they haven't
written it and they don't have access to
the data for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you